people thought when they got off the
buses they were going to be arrested or
apprehended
and i think that the governor abbott's
what he's doing is just so inhumane you
know it's the latest stunt from the
governor another stunt of of bussing
bussing uh desperate migrants across
across the country
and
he's using them as a political ploy i
mean this is what he's been doing and
it's shameful
look you see new york you see washington
and kind of drowning with a few buses we
used to get over a thousand something
people a day daily and then they just
wouldn't leave because we have the issue
of pullback so at one time we had
several thousand in our sandwich park
and thousands coming in every day if
mcallen could do it and do it well
successfully
they they count with a few bus loans
my initial concern when the governor was
going to
have talked about bussing people up
north was governor how are you going to
do that what authority do you have that
and then we quickly during our
conversation i realized that it was
it was the individuals that voluntarily
wanted to go to those areas when i found
out that it was voluntary well that's
great because that's the ultimate
destination that these individuals want
to go anyway so if it's being provided i
guess at the state of texas expense well
they're a little bit lucky in a sense
and it's fortunate for us that we can
transport them out even sooner so they
don't stay here mcallen the their intent
has never been to stay here in the south
in south texas it's always been to go up
north
a lot of the times the immigrants for
example if they're there they're usually
there because they have family members
that can accept them and take care of
them and that's why they're being
transported to those areas but if the
city of mcallen was able to deal with
thousands of immigrants a day i think
they can handle a few hundred now the
other thing that i think is very
important is that they keep on urging
washington and i mean the president the
senate the congress to
finally finally take care of the issues
instead of just making it a
political football kicking it back and
forth
of course we know nothing's going to
happen right now because of the midterms
but hopefully hopefully something soon
what's very concerning is that of
the encounters they had
19 of the people that were captured were
in the terrorist watch list
so my concern there is more of national
security if 19 people were caught that
were the terrorists watchless how many
others were not
and we're talking about thousands of
thousands of people that are not caught
people don't know what we're
experiencing mcallen is a great area we
were the sixth safest city in the
country last year we were the second
best as far as violent crimes in the
state of texas it's a great area so we
want to make sure we keep it that way
that way and we have to it is not a
border crisis it's more a national issue
and now
now people are sitting